what do you say buck
adventure of a lifetime
past of the call the wild are gushing
about icon Harrison Ford but he's
gushing about his co-star who is
actually a human being on a horse I like
seeing you scratch teri like on set was
like it was fun
he was great he's a talented actor and
so I had somebody I had something to
relate to I wasn't just working with a
spot on the wall and it was a great
advantage to me it's a wonderful guy
very talented actor I think there's no
better moment than Harrison Ford
scratching your ears like oh yeah I know
it was cool I mean we he was my owner
for a couple months and we believed it I
was his dog yeah you're like hair
support I'm gonna be your dog that's how
we introduced ourselves we said okay I'm
gonna treat you like a dog and he patted
me on the head and we just carried on
from there you're like on all fours yeah
he's my size but is my size when I'm on
these arm extensions so it's perfect it
was a it was perfect hey just happen
that way the relationship
that my character has with walk the dog
and the value they bring to each other
out of the in the context of that
relationship buck finds his destiny and
the character that I play John Thornton
redeems humanity in buck sighs buck has
had a rough go of it and finally he's
treated with the dignity and respect
that he that he that is his destiny and
it's a very
charming story
[Music]